it's great to Welcome to the program
today Tim Maudlin who's the founder and
director of the John Bell Institute for
the foundations of physics and also
professor of philosophy at New York
University really appreciate your time
today
thanks for having me so let's let's get
into metaphysics a little bit and give
some some in our audience some tools
with which to understand this concept
very often people on the internet love
making videos about metaphysics and they
seem to have no idea what we're even
talking about so so you know one analogy
that I've used and you tell me whether
this gets us in the right direction if
we want to understand
how the moon got to exist and where it
is
gravity would be part of of
understanding that metaphysics would
look at how did Gravity get created was
there a before gravity is that is that
an example of what we talk about when we
say physics versus metaphysics well
unfortunately just the language physics
and metaphysics makes it sound like what
you just said a lot of people use it
that way historically that's not what it
is at all okay metaphysics there was a
document that came down to us from
Aristotle that a later editor called the
metaphysics Aristotle never used the
term and what he's doing in that is
looking at what we call ontology or just
the general theory of what exists
carried out at the most General high
level scale right so not geez there you
know is there a rock over here but are
there rocks at all and what are rocks
made of so from that point of view
it's not that that you go beyond physics
to do metaphysics I actually have a book
called The metaphysics within physics
because physics makes postulates about
at a fundamental level what exists
that's part of metaphysics now maybe not
everything is physical so metaphysics
would go further than that if they're
non-physical things but part of it is
just the basic picture of what exists
physically now if gravity exists
physically okay yeah gravity is part of
it is there a story about where gravity
came from maybe maybe not maybe that's
just kind of ground level stuff once you
get down to the law of gravity there's
no further account of that that's the
the bottom level of everything
when we think about things like the
relationship between mind and body which
can have religious aspects to the
discussion scientific philosophical
Consciousness Free Will these sorts of
things are are these all conversations
that include both what we might consider
traditional hard science as well as
metaphysics or are they only that
depending on the preconceived notions
one brings to the conversation
no I mean the sorts of questions you're
asking certainly the mind-body problem
uh
involves fundamental metaphysical
questions if you think there is a
non-physical Soul some people do some
people don't if you do then there's an
issue of how it can interact with a
physical body right and that the
interaction would have to go both ways
if you think there isn't then you have
to say well how is it that just physical
stuff doing something could give rise to
Consciousness and awareness that's a
very deep problem as well so there's no
easy answers here they're different
answers and each answer kind of involves
its own uh questions that that that run
on from it so yeah I mean metaphysics
certainly gets involved in those kinds
of questions when I've talked to
scientists about the question what was
there before the universe
answers obviously are always couched and
we don't actually know but one question
is was there really a before the
universe which is a hard thing to think
about because it seems as if you
understand time linearly that there must
have been some before some beginning or
something like that what what does
metaphysics have to add to that question
well it's not that metaphysics is going
to ride to the rescue and and provide
answers to this I mean the questions you
ask again are good questions
is there anything before let's say this
universe now one possible answer to that
is yeah there was another universe and
before that maybe another one and before
that maybe another and then there's a
question of how one arises out of
another maybe you say as you say one
possible answer is look there was no
before this universe
um and that might be because time goes
on forever or it might be that time
doesn't even go on forever but
nonetheless there's only so much of it
you sort of there's only a limited
amount this is the kind of standard Big
Bang Theory you go back
13.7 billion years and there is nothing
before that so it's not that that came
out of anything earlier there was no
earlier these are different answers
right and and
cosmologists have proposed different
theories that answer these questions in
different ways it's not as if
metaphysicians have some magic wand that
they're going to give you the right
answer if you're well trained in
philosophy you can at least delineate
look there's this answer there's this
answer there's this answer let's see how
they differ let's see what observations
might bear on this and questions like
that I think one of the areas where lay
people sometimes come up against I don't
know if frustration or despair or
existential crises is the right term but
with some of these questions what
becomes tough is that it can seem as
though you either have to say I'm going
to try to answer some of these questions
simply with science because that's the
only place where the scientific method
exists and that's all I'm comfortable
with in terms of uh confidence in what
we either do know or don't know or I
have to look at a different path
altogether which would be a philosophy
metaphysics Etc and that can be
frustrating because some people feel
like I'm kind of pre-selecting where the
end point for me is going to be in some
of these questions by choosing one of
these two paths almost like a fork in
the road is that an understandable
frustration but more importantly is it
an accurate uh critique or or
observation maybe is the right word so I
I think you have something particular in
mind there and let me just point it out
because you say oh there's the
scientific way and then there are other
ways well I'm saying if someone feels
that way are they right or is that not
the right interpretation or
understanding the the first thing I
would say is sort of any discipline
where you provide what we think as good
reasons to believe what you're proposing
yeah count as a kind of science
sometimes that's experimental or
observational but notice when we divide
the university into the Arts and
Sciences the math departments and the
Sciences right yeah because it works on
observations but because it works by
arguments by proofs right you say look I
have a reason that I can give to you for
for accepting this answer from that
point of view anything that really has
good evidence any anybody that's putting
forward good evidence for what they're
claiming is doing science whatever else
you call it and if something doesn't
count as science then you're just saying
well I'm putting forward opinions and I
have no good reasons for them and I
would say well that's not such a great
thing to do now there are limits to
science there may be things that you'd
like to know that we're just not in a
position to know and if there are there
are I mean you just have to live you
know live with the limitations of the
world
what are in your mind some of the most
interesting questions or problems that
are being looked at
um in in terms of metaphysics and
philosophy right now that maybe maybe
familiar to our audience or may not be
well since I specialize in foundations
of physics the one you mentioned like
how do is there a beginning to the
entire universe Cosmos and if so what
was it like and could there be anything
that we would count as an explanation
for why it was like that I think that's
a very interesting question there are
much more detailed questions about how
to understand quantum theory what you
you know the what picture of the world
that you can really comprehend
could result in the kind of phenomena we
see in the lab that we associate with
quantum theory they're very interesting
I mean I could go into detailed
questions there but I'm sure that would
go take us beyond the scope of this this
interview but
um I work in foundations of physics so
of course
I tend to those there are people who are
worried about how did Life Begin right
that's how how could living things have
have come out of non-living things
um and that's a very interesting
question I mean and and I've heard
interesting answers having to do with
how clay forms and you know various kind
of inorganic structures that could help
create the sorts of complexity that we
need for life and so on um that would be
in biology an interesting question
um so there are lots of them in
different places I happen to live in the
in the physics part of it
I uh recently read a couple of books
about solipsism and one of the claims
that all of these books made was that
unlike with many other philosophies of
reality and time
there's been no refutation satisfactory
refutation of the idea that all we can
really be certain of is our own
existence right now as we are thinking
about it that even our memories that we
believe we have experienced
we may not actually have experienced
them they they may have been implanted
in our brains as you and I are speaking
today in other words I don't know that I
really had an apple an hour ago I have
the memory of having had that apple and
that there's been no uh satisfactory
refutation of that doesn't mean that it
is that it is true
to to choose this when it comes to
thinking about time and the passage of
time Etc what is someone who do the does
the work you do think about such an
assertion well let me just check because
there's a little linguistic question I
have you said you read books about
solipsism did you mean that or
skepticism because it sounded like you
were right I meant solipsism you meant
solipsism well solipsism is a view it's
a very definite view it sort of says the
only thing that exists is me
I mean that that okay that's a possible
view it's kind of crazy
I mean there's so even Someone Like You
is comfortable refuting it by saying
it's kind of crazy well
okay if you want by a refutation and
absolute proof you're not gonna get it
okay but it's not that the solipsist has
an absolute proof of any sort that
solipsism is true so you can't you can't
give that standard to your enemies you
say you enemies you have to prove your
case Beyond any doubt and me I can just
say whatever I want right so it's a
question of burden of proof in a sense
so you know
um solipsism I mean the view that only I
exist I think has literally nothing to
say for
um of course there are things other than
me there are tables and chairs and if I
leave the room as Hume would say if I
leave the room and the fire is burning
and I come back later it's a bunch of
Ashes why because it kept burning all
the time when I wasn't there I mean
that's the obvious explanation it's not
you know you can say I could make up
maybe I'm in The Matrix maybe there's
some ETS you can always make up stuff
yes but there's no reason to believe the
stuff you make up and there's the the
whole picture we have the physical
Universe hangs together and allows you
to make predictions and explain a lot of
stuff that requires there to be more
than just me so I would say all the
evidence is in favor of it not being
just me and none of the evidence now
it's not an absolute proof okay so
you're just asking too much for an
absolute proof and reasonable people
don't demand absolute proof they they
adjust their beliefs to where the weight
of the evidence is with many of these
questions I've asked folks like Lawrence
Krauss for example about it and and
others do you believe that it's a matter
of time until we answer some of these
toughest questions or do you think it's
possible that they will never be
answered
um I I think but you you have to be
prepared for both outcomes because
we don't have the resources to answer
that the best we can say is that you
know people sometimes say look human
intelligence evolved among ape-like
creatures on the Savannah it allowed
them to survive it gave enough
intelligence to deal with that World
um what makes you think that that makes
you smart enough or have the right kind
of intelligence to deal with questions
of cosmology or whatever on the other
hand you certainly have to say well
we've done awfully well I mean we've
extended science down to to microscopic
and subatomic scales and to cosmological
scales and we understand a lot about
Galaxy formation and everything so
certainly our intellectual abilities go
far beyond what we needed just in order
to survive how far will they take us
will they take us to an end as it were
Theory that's just the Right theory that
always makes the right predictions or
will we get stuck I don't know I mean
the only way to find out is to push
forward right the only way to find out
is to figure out what we don't know now
and investigate the possible ways to go
forward and push as hard as you can to
make a a prediction about whether we'll
succeed or not
I you know I guess I tend to be kind of
optimistic but I but that's just a
character trait of mine that's not an
argument
I I share that uh cautious optimism that
that some at some point what are the
time scales we're thinking of though I
think is where it becomes a tougher
question uh we've been speaking with Tim
Maudlin who is a professor of philosophy
at New York University you have an
ongoing project you wanted to mention as
well is that right yes I did just since
I have people's attention if you're
interested in these issues um I am the
founder and director of the John Bell
Institute for the foundations of physics
we are at the moment trying to raise
money on a GoFundMe to buy a a location
where we can exist physically so if
anybody would like to help us out we
would appreciate any help you can give
us you can just uh Google John Bell
Institute to our website or the GoFundMe
John Bell Institute and it would come up
that's a John
bellinstitute.org as the website uh Tim
Maudlin really appreciate your time and
insights today thank you thank you